next free atlanta trying to get back to
10 games over 500 and birdie as you said
in the open he's been great and he's
been terrific especially over the last
seven
chisholm chases he is a strikeout
machine that's 124 of them
and two are up to it out amount for the
marlins it is edward cabrera making his
fourth major league start first time he
sees the braves figures to see them
quite a bit throughout his career
ozzy one for 10 in the series
it's last time out two in the third
innings four runs all earned and four
walks one strikeout for
cabrera who has already matched that
total by
getting albies
payoff pitch from cabrera
and
freeman golf's one out toward right
center field it will be de la cruz to
make the catch
a one two three first inning for edward
cabrera scoreless afternoon
first pitch to jesus sanchez swings hits
into the air pretty well center field
this baby's got a chance kiss it goodbye
into the little reservoir dead central
yes
wow that ball was touched i mean that
ball was
on a streak a 460 foot home run the
longest
of sanchez's season 46 strikeouts and 84
at bats
not this time though he hits one a long
way to left twisting and turning on the
warning track and the grab made by
rosario he hit that a country mile
02 to darno
this one popped up
and joe panicking foul territory jazz
bobbles it and makes the catch
now panic waved his arms first thought
he was settled underneath it but
jazz maybe had a little bit of a better
angle you always like the second baseman
really to take over because he's got
more lateral movement
i think for jazz
those quick hands came in handy
so with two quick outs peterson picks up
the first braves hit now cabrera behind
in the count three and one
and he walks dansby and that'll bring up
eddie rosario
with the braves threatening for the
first time in the second inning
2-2
called strike three inside quarter
rosario thought it was in but it swung
back around for a strikeout
at this point freed looks like he's
playing a video game
and he got rojas to expand his strike
zone and max free just struck out the
side
he has punched out five he'll try to
start a rally in the atlanta third
ozzy struck out his first time shift is
on
scary though man that guy was the best
there's a shot to right for ozzy albee's
he needed that
his fourth hit on the home stand a
one-out single here in the third inning
patience
and power for the braves first baseman
who now awaits a 3-2 pitch
and he earns ball four that got away
from jackson and albie's will move up an
extra 90 feet an opportunity knocks for
austin reilly wiggle them fingers down
2-2 pitches a change-up in there called
strike three
rung them up on a change up
top of the zone
eddie turn the game around right here
make him pay for these free passes
so dansby will take off with two outs
there he goes the 3-2 swaying and a fly
ball hammered toward the braves bullpen
daylight crews sprinting looking
it's gone braves lead 2-1
look at this pitch
struck him out on the inside pitch i
think he missed his spot right there he
was trying to go in but that ball came
right back across the middle of the
plate and rosario goes yaya straight
away center field you gotta love it
you know a couple of pitches ago it
looked like cabrera hopped off the mound
and i wasn't sure if he was just
frustrated with a pitch that got away
it was that one uh yeah right there
did a spike get caught looks like he
might be favoring that right ankle right
leg
it looks like cabrera may be coming out
of this ball game
with as many home runs as the braves
that's the first one that they have hit
in this series
but at the moment a big one it gives
them a 2-1 lead cabrera leaves
he got him with a breaking ball alvarez
couldn't catch up seven strikeouts for
max freed
brian that's why he's a pitcher
two one atlanta has the lead
solaris grounded out a couple of times
still looking to extend the hitting
streak to 10 games to equal his career
high and wednesday the finale 12 20.
line drive down the left field line
that's in for a hit that one will get
into the corner for an extra base hit
for solaire helmet flying is around
first and he stands at second with a two
base hit to extend his hitting streak
equaling a career high at 10.
hard headline drive base hit here comes
solaire around third brinson will
concede the run
the last seven runs in this series for
the braves have come with two outs
and darno picks up freeman and reilly
who couldn't move solaire up atlanta
extends the lead it's now three to one
in the picture spot sixth inning
we'll see the marlins suppose could
double switch him into this ball game if
they'd like
probably wouldn't make much sense unless
they get down to panic that would be
good here's the swing of the high five
ball hit pretty well deep center field
back is peterson still going back it
rattles off the base of the wall it took
a really hard hop it's
rolling out into center field
ground ball left side and through an rbi
single for miguel rojas the marlins inch
closer as diaz scores
and the tying run is at first now
biggest pitch of the game right here max
freed
can he execute o2 pitch
this is going to drop in for a base hit
and sanchez has tied the game miggy rose
scores
now you got to love the approach with
sanchez today i mean he is thinking
about keeping his hands tight to the
body and inside the baseball against
freed
on the ground
dansby's gonna have to hurry his throat
at first and he got it there in time he
got panic
braves were in a shift panic rolls out
and the marlins get it tied with two
runs in the sixth
jacob webb will follow max freed
and a swing and a miss that's something
alex has got to figure out
good start for webb he retires his
former teammate
one out base is clean for ozzy albee's
ozzy fly ball belted deep right field
stay up it's gone braves are back in
front
two hits for all bees homer number 28
4-3 atlanta
and we've seen him do it time after time
come back with a big hit late in the
ball game
[Applause]
that was just an outstanding and bad he
got the pitch he wanted and he did not
miss it he is over two
freeman shoots one toward left that
one's got a chance happy birthday to you
i knew it was coming you called it bj
things happened on your birthday and
freddie was not gonna lead his ballpark
without hitting the home run
and he goes i'll pull taco with it
[Applause]
smith looking for his 30-second save
this one's in the air and it's hit
pretty well it's carrying out by the
wall and it's off the wall
jesus sanchez is on his way to second
and he's not going to stop there on his
way to third
with a triple 50 versus lefty from will
smith here it is
a flinch and he had a great at bat
didn't chase any of those four that were
around the plate now they're at the
corners
tying runs iran and jackson the hitter
first and third one out
popped him up
freddie freeman says he's got it foul
groud
two outs and alvarez is not that hitter
uh easy hitter we saw how far he hit a
home run the other day two on two out
ground ball right he's got it he's gonna
go the long way and the braves win
the braves take two out of three from
the marlins
you